[Musica]
il 20 settembre 2017 andava online la
prima puntata di vita buttata per quasi
quattro anni Grazie specialmente a voi
Ho raccolto esperienze di centinaia di
persone a vita buttata se è parlato
tante volte de merda ma insieme alle
storie dei vostri sfinteri abbiamo avuto
modo di conoscere anche tante persone
che sono state nostre ospiti la novità
oltre al meraviglioso set buttato e che
avremo tre ospiti da mettere in mezzo e
non più i vostri audio bensì un video
mandato da voi che ci mostri Comunque la
retta via ho la felicità di introdurvi
Innanzitutto un imprenditrice di
successo ma
che cazzo è questa
m'è venuta apposta che è pian piano
questa
Ok per cui iniziamo Anzi scusami eh No
aiuto
Oggi
siamo inizio alla prima puntata di vita
buttata theshowsha
un imprenditrice di successo un
intenditrice d'arte abbiamo una
filantropa abbiamo Cristina fogazzi
Cristina buongiorno buongiorno Abbiamo
una donna che ha il potere di strappare
una risata a chiunque Nel senso che te
la piglia e la toglie totalmente è una
Food Blogger una chef autrice di se
stessa allieva di Iginio Massari ma
anche perito chimico abbiamo qui con noi
Sofia Fabiani
cucinare stanca altrimenti Ma io non
posso salutare saluta Buonasera e infine
abbiamo un attore un doppiatore
un'indossatrice un sexy simbolo una
escort ma anche un sano portatore
d'ansia torna con noi Cosma Ciao
Gin tonic per tutti quanti hanno
alcolico e io che bevo un gin governo
alcolico
dell'alcol capito Scusate raga questo
qui è sempre un tempo morto da sempre
quindi non mi rompete il cazzo tu
facessi tutto velocemente come si vedeva
in televisione ma allora non è tutto
vero È carina così ingenuo
partiamo con una nuova puntata di vita
buttata vita buttata uh
[Musica]
Io vorrei partire con te Qui è una
storia pazzesca se ci pensi Ora non so
se tu conosci sono curioso Perfetto
allora io te la leggo proprio lei nel
2009 nel 2009 avevi 35 anni
Ma come si permette Forse di meno 30
anni sono 48 mi ha fatto conto veramente
eh Comunque questo centro estetico
chiude tu eri già molto brava ti metti
in proprio con grandissima difficoltà e
adesso Eccola qua vai ti lascio il
testimone Sì E adesso ragazzi è
diventata una dell'imprenditrici più
importanti d'Italia
Ok aggiungiamo due note a Piè pagina No
perché se uno dice questa apre un centro
estetico Moccia li troviamo qua in
Brindisi cioè l'imprenditrice milionaria
alberi di Natale gioco ha sposato uno
con i soldi no In quegli anni Bui è
triste in cui si compravano i
trattamenti estetici su Groupon come
pubblicizzare un centro estetico senza
soldi all'epoca c'era Facebook e le
aziende di solito su Facebook Non ci
andavano perché sembravi poco serio
tutto bene
E mettiamo su questa pagina in vignette
che diventano un po' virali e su
Facebook Fai conto avremmo avuto 20 30
mila follower non c'era ancora Instagram
non esisteva Capisco che per voi è un
trauma però incredibile Non c'è ancora
Instagram i video si mettevano su
YouTube e poi li ripostavi su Facebook
e poi decidiamo che senza parlare di
centro estetico quindi vignette
diventano virali facciamo vedere queste
estetiste esiste quindi cominciamo a
mettere dei video da YouTube Se vai a
vedere il mio canale YouTube t'ammazzi
dal ridere trovi Ma certo
a questo punto riveliamo l'esistenza di
un centro estetico ma questo ci serviva
per far pubblicità al centro estetico
siccome c'era questa visibilità online
che consisteva in Boh fai 50.000
follower su Facebook e se vai indietro
nel mio Instagram per avere le cose in
vereconde 2.500 su Instagram mettiamo su
un e-commerce che all'inizio vende
quattro creme e poi avendo 5 le
mettevamo sottovuoto noi al centro
estetico
non avevamo i soldi per fare le scatole
quindi mi ero inventata con un
pannellino in Forex appoggiate sopra
nella sottovuotatrice con la plastichina
Quella quella
volta devo comprare la metro i sacchetti
abbiamo comprato la sottovuotatrice
professionale alla metro e
sottovuotavamo al centro estetico e
spedivamo quello che mi segue il sito
che ovviamente è un po' smettono Ma
perché non fai il black friday dico che
è Black Friday Eh ma lo sai che adesso
si usa negli Stati nei negozi online
senza fare perché si faceva solo online
una volta il black friday me lo fanno
tutti facciamo gli sconti e quel giorno
vendiamo €7000 di roba io Steve Jobs io
Steve Jobs
quindi di sera finiamo di lavorare e ci
fermiamo a preparare i pacchi da lì è
cominciata a crescere Tu fai conto che
l'anno scorso Esatto
durante il black friday dell'anno scorso
17 milioni
Quasi come 7.000
l'anno dei 7000 i due i due Le due
chiavi di volta sono state l'anno dei
7.000 e credo l'anno in cui abbiamo
fatto tipo un milione due Black Friday
che per me hai capito un milione di euro
quest'anno Tu stai per fare una cosa
pazzesca insieme alla tua azienda perché
a Milano in Piazza Duomo il Natale
quest'anno ce lo porta vera Lab io ho
qui una serie di alberi di Natale che
Vorrei commentare commentare con voi per
capire se ci avviciniamo o no a quello
che stai per creare allora
un gioco coi gatti
Uh ma sono verdi condom
Hearts Augusto il verde ad esempio c'è
quello alla fragola che è rosso
ragazzi
Bello ma più tradizionale
una persona che fa una cosa così
esattamente
se ci fosse la tua faccia bello ma non è
specificarello No questo è tutto bello
però stanotte bello non ci voglio più
venire mi piace aver pensato
quell'albero così tradizionale quando
potevamo fare questo però questa è la
vita questa sei te finta assomiglia
Guarda guarda questi qui erano delle dei
suggerimenti Sofia a questo punto
abbiamo fatto una chiacchiera sugli
alberi che cos'è la tocca a me già mi
hai detto che non faccio ridere no ti
sto dicendo tu hai una bellissima pagina
su Instagram
problemi preferite
Io mi guardo tutto quanto l'oroscopo è
stanco ma c'avrò anche una rubrica per
l'oroscopo standard
possiamo dire che una delle mie
preferite in assoluto lui apre il mio
profilo per la prima volta ora
velocissimo
di merda bene Come ti è nata questa
voglia così di entrare all'interno delle
sciagure delle persone ma io avevo
raccontato una figura di merda che avevo
fatto con mio padre ma una Ma figurati
se tu Sofia così composta riesce a fare
delle brutte figure Io non credo Credo a
casa di un'amica e mando questo
messaggio a mia sorella Non dire a papà
che sto qua ma mi sa che faremo
l'amore a chi lo invio a mio padre
non ci credo
a mio padre Mio padre mi risponde
Tranquilla amore io ho fatto due figli
lo so che cosa succede alla tua età
comunque vogliamo vederci un pochino di
figure di merda che ti hanno mandato
Prova a fotografare il tipo che mi piace
in biblioteca ma parte il flash e se ne
accorge Sì ragazzi Veramente Ma com'è
possibile
e poi me ne sono andata in bagno
Instagram aperto Abbassa le mutande
guardo il tele aveva attivato una
diretta
di capitale credibile Volevo cercare
tipo su Facebook da cell invece scrivo
il suo nome e cognome come è status e
poi si spegne il cell
io supervisiono esame lui sciarpa sulle
gambe che copre chiedo di spostarla
durello Ma che vuol dire ed era venuto
duro che mi hai spiegato che viene il
sangue sul pisello e ti viene duro
spiegato a 35 anni t'ho spiegato io che
il sangue assumere per alle tue
responsabilità a un certo punto della
tua vita sai no perché questo
continuamente Cercare di evitare le
proprie retugliela e spiegato con
numerosi testimoni io però senza aver
mai avuto diciamo un'esperienza diretta
so che c'è un omettamento Cos'è un
umettamento Esatto
colloquio in inglese Volevo dire che
avevo esperienza ai lavori manuali and
job Cosma tu che sei un attore Martin No
però se è vero a te hanno mai chiesto
favori sessuali per una parte no ma
quindi questo mi sul fatto che bisogna
darla usando io conosco diverse storie
scabrose a riguardo
un mio amico proprio amico aveva
conosciuto uno sceneggiatore che era
Vecio cioè molto anziano capito Mi ha
detto se mi fai una spatrilla ti faccio
Scusate per
proprio no Ah ok No perché no ti spiego
Mi sembrava Peppino sei Pipino Peppino
Esatto madre inoltra tutti i video di
fiori senza vederlo tutto dai fiori di
schivavano peni enormi Sì queste sono
quelle robe da boomer al museo mi
rincorrono per il biglietto io scappo
convinta che il tipo fosse un me
[Applauso]
Vorremmo un attimo fare un piccolo
lancio anche per te perché sennò pare
che esatto che i monopolizzi questa
domanda Esatto
Tu hai una newsletter meraviglioso che
si chiama che mangiamo possiamo dire
Cosa c'è all'interno di questa
newsletter quindi si ricette di cui un
dolce
vegana e anche senza glutine anche per
celiaci dolci e 4 articoli al mese di
quattro contributors molto validi ed è
qui che voglio arrivare proprio da te
Cosma la newsletter è un qualcosa di
meraviglioso e che secondo me va a
toccare esattamente ciò di cui voglio
parlare con te Cosma ad oggi
se non gli avessero chiuso almeno tre
volte ti hanno chiuso i profili
la prima volta
Guarda me mi era arrivato un messaggio
no una Meo con scritto Ah sei perfetto
per avere la spunta blu e non vedevo
l'ora stavo a 120 mila ancora qua
anch'io
Dopo mezz'ora non riuscivo più a entrare
ma chissà perché e poi la sera vedo
l'immagine di un turco che stava così
stupido
e poi ha iniziato a mettere storie
scrivendo ragazze foto nude ragazze che
ho detto Porco due
cioè avrebbe capito preso da quel
magazzino tutte le nuditè tutte le
srollette e ce ne sono in quel magazzino
Poi per fortuna non è mai successo poi
la seconda volta se permetta Adesso
parlo io che mi sono svegliato ho fatto
Un simpatico doppiaggio no con due
bambini asiatici che stavano sul vasino
e si prendevano a parole No io ho detto
parole un po' forti evidentemente
Instagram è non le posso dire
risveglianza ad oggi tu avresti avuto
una infinità di persone che ti segue
invece tu ogni volta come l'araba Fenice
sei risorto
Okay
ma se tu avessi avuto una newsletter
tutto questo non sarebbe mai successo
qua appiccicati al tuo pettorale tonico
tonico ragazze tonico
ho sentitissimo per favore no quello che
volevo dire quindi è so che ultimamente
poi ti sei aperto anche a un nuovo mondo
a Tik Tok ultimamente
Ultimamente
è un anno che Marco
Tik Tok
ma preferirei i milioni capito
Ok Io so però che allo stesso tempo Tu
hai un problema con Tik Tok ed è una
cosa invece seria legato alla creatività
Ma come fai a sapere queste cose tu Io
ho un'ottima relazione tu hai parlato di
un problema che tu hai incontrato di voi
cioè sul fatto di non sapere cosa fare
Sì è sul fatto anche questo anni che
vado avanti parlando a chiunque cosa non
so più che fare sui social e tutti anzi
sei bravo [ __ ] però cioè non è sì ma
soprattutto sono grande Cosa vuol dire
cioè io penso no ne ho 37 sai che cosa
devi fare uscire da quella porta
immediatamente
piccolo secondo te no grande No è un
problema perché tutti vedi no tu lo
sbirci lo smaneggio Sì lo smaneggio
Esatto E tu vedi questi bambini a parte
i balletti e poi fanno
ognuno di noi vuole essere accettato in
qualche modo sbaglio
però perché tu hai dei Binari molto
solidi Ognuno ha il suo modus operandi
Ok c'è la ballerina che ballano
i panini e Megapolis
Io penso mi guardo allo specchio Ma che
dici a volte mi guardo allo specchio si
succede e dico ma io cosa sono
No no like the
breadè qualcuno voleva dire in questo
studio Grazie anche capisci
un tatuaggio esce giù un tatuaggio amo
dai sempre Mezzojuso Ma io faccio le
voci che non è questa cosa sarò un
discreto attore faccio i doppiaggini Ma
io che cazzo devo portare
mi capisci
Per carità sempre gli anni non voi che
ci state guardando siete il pubblico
elettrico Tik Tok poi ci sono anche
delle persone che magari non sono però
però non voi a voi è mai capitato mi
posso fare una domanda io a voi scusami
avrei messo delle distanze Se avessi
saputo dicendo No ma prima Cioè ero
raffreddato capito
giustamente anch'io che ti senti un po'
un pesce fuor d'acqua possiamo dirla
così
subito
sta succedendo Vi è mai successo che voi
portate un contenuto che magari pensate
al momento una cagata
il tuo gusto se fai solo le cose che
piacciono a te
Cioè io non farei niente Tu ti devi
dimenti cioè devi pensare che c'hai
tante persone diverse davanti a te una
priorità
con gusti diversi dai tuoi Quindi quello
che tu A volte dici questo spacca sicuro
ti piace solo a te Povera deficiente Non
solo a volte invece c'è un contenuto
dice questo è un contenuto de Cristo
Esatto
Però a volte funziona anche tanto il
contenuto in cui la gente perde la
dignità e noi non ce l'abbiamo più l'età
per più per per la dignità però scusami
è questa è la prima regola che vi vorrei
che mi vorrei dare la seconda certo
certo la seconda amici non essere mai
troppo innamorati della propria idea
Però scusami
le proprie idee perché a volte tu pensi
che il contenuto che piace alle persone
sia quello cioè ma non è così Devi
essere anche capace di capire che a lei
piace tanto spiegare la sabbiatura della
frolla sabbia dicendo
Quindi la mia domanda è esattamente è
giusto e volevo arrivare proprio lì
pensa un po' a te se io non mi diverto e
faccio una cagata che voglio
ma riformuliamola insieme cioè quindi tu
pensi se io non seguo quello che
spontaneamente sarebbe la voce del mio
animo creativo Ma presto il fianco
invece all'odies
tradiscono me stesso
questa è la domanda posso ribaltare una
domanda vuoi ancora non risposto ma
cos'è veramente Qual è vai vai vai vai
No no no no no no no no no no qual è il
tuo quello che funziona meglio non ne ho
la più pallida idea
partner
se non sono un doppiatore vero Siediti
subito secondo me tanto quanto io mi
sono chiamato estetista cinica Perché te
la buttavo un po' in vacca tanto quanto
tu che non fai doppiaggio perché mi dici
non sono un doppiatore professionista ti
posso dare tre regole Cristina perché tu
non sembri sceso dalla Valle Bresciana
anche a me effettivamente D'altronde in
modo molto divertente Cioè se tu
correggesti me come sei cretino tu
ridono per 45 minuti che mi dice Non
dire o così oh vorresti vedere un
doppiaggio live
[Musica]
mi dai un po' di soldi
[Risate]
senza ditalia era solo uno scherzo amici
Comunque
ragazzi siamo siamo in diretta dai Cosma
siamo io vorrei così tornare un attimo
dalla persona da cui siamo partiti Cri
tu hai fatto veramente di tutto e di più
oggi in generale la vita ma io so che a
breve sta per uscire lui il mio Grand
Tour che il nuovo libro di estetista
scenica che esce il 29 il 27 del 29 il 6
si accende l'albero di Natale ma tu le
vacanze le fai comunque ti rilasso
il Multicentrum in questo periodo
comunque un integratore a caso due
parole per parlarmi di questo nuovo
progetto ma vorrei che tu ne leggessi
proprio uno stralcio per noi allora
stiamo scherzando perché io non ho il
libro e quindi gli ho portato un mockup
Amazon
quindi diciamo che c'è l'unione fra
quella che è l'esperienza dell'arte
italiana ma allo stesso tempo
Ciao i pezzi della mia storia o
considerazione Insomma fatte da vecchie
belli in bocca al lupo ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questa puntata
prima di salutarci Io vi avevo promesso
che avrei condiviso con voi uno dei
video che ci sono arrivati tra parentesi
Vi prego continuateli a mandare sono
video nei quali Vi chiediamo di
mostrarci Come avete buttato la vostra
vita in alcuni momenti mandateceli nel
profilo del Winwood Steam è sempre più
difficile da fare andando avanti col
tasto
analcolemico Io vi faccio vedere e
condivido con voi questa ragazza giorno
della sua laurea lei è felicissima ma
sbagliano una cosa di tempismo
Guardatela
deve fare una foto
dietro del padre lei è qui per prendere
Capito Dopo anni di studio e ha creato
il suo momento
con i coriandoli tempismo papà mi
raccomando
Sai che non lo so perché Ma che è
[Musica]
Pensavo che mi stava a sentire male
Francesca noi ti auguri auguri
in faccia No è una roba che ti ammazza
Allora noi l'abbiamo scoppiati in
ufficio dove abbiamo un cartongesso
bucato il cartongesso veramente cosa
Oddio non ci credo comunque ad ogni modo
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine della
di questa nostra rubrica no bisogna
dirlo Allora io vorrei un attimo fare al
volo una foto per la tunnel la
presentazione
secondo copertina
centrale Perfetto allora Facciamo
partire il countdown 1 2 3
Oddio Ecco cosa hai bevuto questo è un
povero pazzo lui sta a pezzi
le gocce d'acqua
[Applauso]
chiamiamo qualcuno
io ho mangiato questo
l'uovo Grazie ancora a Cristina fogazzi
per essere stata mia ospite in bocca al
lupo con l'albero col Punk friday in
bocca al lupo col libro Cosma In bocca
al lupo con qualsiasi cosa trova la tua
via Ti prego fallo per tutti noi e anche
alla meravigliosa Sofia
seguitela cucinare stanca di newsletter
è pazzesca profilo meraviglioso grazie a
tutti quanti voi Un bacio ciao alla
prossima Ciao grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]